OK, here's what intrigued Ben. His friend Sonari had told him that he'd come up with this thing. And there's no way to say this without sounding like an infomercial, but Sonari was doing this thing that was saving him lots of money.
好的，Ben对此很感兴趣。他的朋友Sonari告诉他，他想出了一个点子。如果不说得像电视购物广告那样听起来太夸张，Sonari确实发现了一个能为他省下不少钱的方法。
And Sonari is exactly the kind of person who would know about this kind of thing. He's a business reporter. He's one of our colleagues at NPR News. Anyway, here's Ben.
Sonari正是那种会关注此类事情的人。他是一位商业记者。他是我们在NPR新闻部的同事之一。总之，这是Ben的故事。
He told me he was just saving on everything. Like he used it for shoes, for clothes, big stuff like new tires.
他告诉我，他几乎在所有事情上都能省钱。比如他买鞋、买衣服，还有像换新轮胎这样的大件物品。
Ben, by the way, is This American Life producer Ben Calhoun. He and Sonari are buddies, and Ben says that Sonari came up with this new financial strategy one day when Sonari was shopping for shoes.
顺便提一下，Ben是《This American Life》的制作人Ben Calhoun。他和Sonari是好友，Ben说Sonari是在某天买鞋时偶然想出这个财务策略的。
And he realized that all the shoes that he wanted were the super expensive shoes.
他意识到，他看中的所有鞋子都是那种超级昂贵的鞋。
Oh.
噢。
Yeah. Yeah. And he keeps coming back to this pair that's way too expensive. And he stays there for hours stressing about this decision, until finally he caved.
对，没错。他总是对那双贵得离谱的鞋念念不忘。他在那里待了好几个小时，为这个决定感到苦恼，直到最后他妥协了。
So he's like, I'm just gonna do it. I'm gonna do it. I'm gonna do it. So he got up to the counter, and this is what he says happened.
所以他想，我一定要买下它。我一定要买。我一定要买。于是他走到柜台前，这就是他所说的当时发生的事情。
I remembered this thing a guy that I'd interviewed had talked about, about the good guy discount.
我记起曾经采访过的一个人提到过的事情，关于“好人折扣”。
The good guy discount?
“好人折扣”？
The good guy discount. This is the thing. Sonari, he'd interviewed this negotiations expert from Columbia University Business School.
“好人折扣”。事情就是这样。Sonari曾采访过哥伦比亚大学商学院的一位谈判专家。
And the guy told him about this technique where you say, can I get a good guy discount on that? You're a good guy. I'm a good guy. Come on, just a good guy discount.
那个人告诉他一种技巧，你可以说：“我能享受‘好人折扣’吗？你是好人，我也是好人。拜托，就给个‘好人折扣’吧。”
And this works for the professor?
这对那位教授真的管用吗？
Yeah. It's supposed to be like a thing.
是的。这据称是一种招数。
Wow.
哇。
So Sonari remembered this when he was about to buy these shoes. And honestly, he didn't think it was going to work.
所以当Sonari准备买鞋时，他想起了这一点。老实说，他没觉得会成功。
And I go, hey you know, is there a good guy discount? And he goes, what? It's like, you know, you've seen me here all day. You know I want these shoes. It's tough for me, blah, blah, blah.
我说：“嘿，你知道吗，这鞋能打‘好人折扣’吗？”他说：“什么？”我说：“你知道的，你看着我在这里逛了一整天了。你知道我想要这双鞋。对我来说这很难，诸如此类。”
And he looks at me and he goes, I tell you what, brother. And he swiped the card--
他看着我，然后说：“兄弟，我跟你说吧。”然后他刷了卡——
Like his little authorization card?
就像他的那种小额授权卡？
Yeah. And he goes, I'll give you 25% off.
对。他说：“我给你打七五折。”
25% off!
七五折！
Mm hmm.
嗯。
[LAUGHING] It was the most positive reinforcement you could ever get.
[笑] 这简直是你所能得到的最棒的正面反馈了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Like, I was so happy.
当时我简直太开心了。
So Sonari told Ben all this because Sonari had started doing this all the time, asking for the good guy discount. And he thought that Ben should try it too. And Ben suggested this might be a good radio story for our show.
Sonari把这一切都告诉了Ben，因为他已经开始频繁使用这一招，到处询问“好人折扣”。他觉得Ben也应该试试。Ben提出，这或许是我们节目的一段不错的广播素材。
And all of us here at the ratio show, we all said great. And we all told him, of course, as part of the story you're gonna have to go out and try to get the discount yourself. And Ben turned red and started to squirm, but he said sure.
我们广播节目组的所有人都觉得太棒了。当然，我们也告诉他，作为故事的一部分，他必须亲自去尝试争取折扣。Ben脸涨得通红，开始有些坐立不安，但他还是答应了。
And we put it into our story list, and it sat there. And a month went by, and then a second month, and a third-- six months, nine months, 11 months.
我们把它写进了选题单，然后就搁置了。一个月过去了，接着是第二个月、第三个月……六个月，九个月，11个月。
And now and then, one of us would remember this at a story meeting and say, whatever happened to that good guy discount thing? And Ben would get all embarrassed. And it was clear he was just hating the idea that he was  going to actually have to go out in the world and do this thing. He could not bring himself to.
偶尔，我们会在选题会上想起这件事，问道：“那个‘好人折扣’的事情怎么样了？”Ben就会感到非常尴尬。很明显，他非常抵触这个主意，因为他真的得走到现实世界中去执行这件事。他就是过不了自己那一关。
I just could not get over the pitch itself. It's so cheesy.
我就是无法克服这个推销话术本身。它太烂俗了。
To say, I'm a good guy, you're a good guy.
说“我是好人，你是好人”。
Yeah. I think it's kinda smarmy. Like, I love Sonari. I love Sonari. I think that Sonari is a wonderful person. But it traffics in this term of good guy when it's nonsense.
没错。我觉得这有点虚伪。我爱Sonari，真的。我认为Sonari是个很棒的人。但当他拿“好人”这个词来作为一种筹码时，简直荒谬。
It's me saying, I'm a good guy, which I feel like it's the kind of thing of saying like, I'm so humble. The second part of it is you're saying, and the thing I'm going to do as a good guy is I'm going to ask you to do me a favor and cost yourself money. That's what a good guy I am. And I don't know. I find it to be not the behavior of a good guy.
这就好比我在说“我是个好人”，这感觉就像是在说“我是多么谦逊”一样。第二部分是你还在说：“作为好人，我要请你帮个忙，让你自己损失点钱。”这算哪门子好人啊？我不确定，我觉得这根本不是一个好人的行为。
A good guy, Ben said, would not make somebody else uncomfortable on purpose. And he was convinced that asking for a good guy discount, it puts the sales person on the spot.
Ben说，一个好人不会故意让别人感到难堪。他坚信，询问“好人折扣”会让销售人员陷入尴尬。
You're asking them to break the rules for you for absolutely no reason. And I hate making other people feel uncomfortable.
你是在要求他们无缘无故地为你破坏规则。我讨厌让别人感到不舒服。
I have a different take on it than you do. I think it shows moxie.
我和你的看法不同。我认为这展现了勇气。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
And the good guy discount is part of what makes this country great, even if Sonari's the only one who's doing it. That impulse of just like, I'm just going to go for it. I'm going to say something that's ridiculous and corny and just see if it works.
而且“好人折扣”是让这个国家变得伟大的原因之一，即使Sonari是唯一一个这么做的人。那种“我就是要去试一试”的冲动。我说出一些荒谬和陈词滥调的话，只是想看看是否奏效。
I mean, you know, in the movies, that's what gets the girl. In the movies, that's what makes you a hero.
我是说，在电影里，这可是能追到女孩的招数。在电影里，这能让你成为英雄。
If I were to try this three times, how many times do you think it would work?
如果我试三次，你觉得能成功几次？
One.
一次。
So here's one question before I go in. Is it important that I do the whole, I'm a good guy, you're a good guy?
好吧，在我出发前还有一个问题。我必须把整套说辞——“我是好人，你是好人”——都说出来吗？
You gotta say something. What else are you gonna say?
你得说点什么。不然你还能说什么？
Well, today on our radio program, good guys. We have four stories including I go with Ben as he tries to find out whether or not he has what it takes to get free stuff by claiming to be a good guy, even though he worries that doing that, trying the entire exercise, means that he is not a good guy at all, because friends, it is a struggle sometimes to know what a good guy would and would not do. And in each of our stories today, we have guys trying to find that line, trying to stay on one side of the line, trying to stay good guys in a world where we all know, that can be very, very difficult.
好吧，今天在我们的广播节目中，我们谈谈“好人”。我们有四个故事，其中一个是我陪Ben去尝试，看他是否有胆量通过自称好人来获取免费物品，尽管他担心尝试这个练习本身就意味着他根本不是个好人。因为朋友们，要明确什么是一个好人会做或不会做的事，有时确实是个难题。在今天我们的每个故事中，都有人在努力寻找那条界限，试图停在界限的一侧，在这个众所周知非常困难的世界里努力做个“好人”。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《This American Life》。我是Ira Glass。请留下来继续收听。
Act One, "Takes One to Know One." So after 11 months of stalling, Ben finally headed out to get himself the good guy discount wearing a microphone hidden underneath his shirt. I went with him.
第一幕，“物以类聚”。在拖延了11个月后，Ben终于戴着藏在衬衫下的麦克风，准备去争取“好人折扣”了。我和他一起去了。
First place we go, a baby store. It's a big national chain. I've bought stuff at this particular store before.
我们去的第一个地方是一家婴儿用品店。这是一家大型连锁店。我以前在这家店买过东西。
And for our test, I chose one of these baby items that's mind blowingly expensive, so much so that it's hard to imagine anyone actually buying it. It's a blanket for a stroller. It cost $190.
为了测试，我挑选了一件贵得离谱的婴儿用品，以至于很难想象有人真的会买它。那是一个婴儿车的毯子，售价190美元。
My thought in doing this is that the markup is probably so insane that it'd make it easier to give a discount. Anyway, so I grab one and I get in line.
我想这样做的话，利润空间可能高得离谱，或许更容易给出折扣。总之，我拿了一个，排队结账。
Now I feel nervous.
现在我感到很紧张。
The whole pitch still makes me queasy. But I'm committed to selling it as best I can. There's one cashier working.
整个推销话术仍然让我感到恶心。但我下定决心要尽我所能把它推销出去。柜台只有一个收银员。
Hey, how you doing today?
嘿，今天过得怎么样？
I'm good, and you?
很好，你呢？
Oh, good.
噢，挺好。
What's the total on that?
那个总共多少钱？
$206.85.
206.85美元。
Is there any way I could get a good guy discount on that?
请问我能享受某种“好人折扣”吗？
Good guy discount? I don't think we do those.
“好人折扣”？我不觉得我们有这种东西。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
It's hard to hear. But when I ask for the discount, she cracks a smile and kind of laughs and says, "Good guy discount? We don't do those."
听不太清。但当我要求折扣时，她露出了微笑，有点想笑，说道：“‘好人折扣’？我们不提供那个。”
Are there any promotions coming up? Or is this going to go on sale any time soon or anything? No, nothing?
最近有什么促销活动吗？或者这东西很快会打折吗？没有吗？
I leave the thing on the counter. So first attempt, we're 0 for one.
我把东西留在了柜台上。所以第一次尝试，我们失败了。
Ira felt like I should have tried harder. And for the next one, I should keep the thing going longer, lean harder on the schtick. I'm a good guy, you're a good guy. What do you say?
Ira觉得我应该再努力一点。下次，我应该把戏演得长一点，更坚持那套说辞。我是好人，你是好人。你觉得怎么样？
I am not so sure. So next stop.
我不确定。所以，下一站。
Yeah, I guess I'll try the nine first. Do they run a little big?
是的，我想我先试试九号。它们码数偏大吗？
This item? Winter boots. We go to a big, big sporting goods store, though not a chain, just in case some strict corporate policy had been the problem at the baby store.
这个商品是冬靴。我们去了另一家非常大的体育用品商店，不过不是连锁店，以防婴儿用品店的问题是源于严格的公司政策。
The following customer can step down.
下一位顾客可以过来。
At the registers, I get called up. There's a woman, maybe late 20s. She's got a lot of makeup. She looks fed up with something. My thought is, I'll smile a little more, be a little more friendly.
到了收银台，我被叫了过去。那是个女人，大概不到30岁。她化了浓妆，看起来对什么事很不耐烦。我的想法是，我会多笑一点，表现得更友善一些。
And I know this is going to sound silly. Is there any way-- is there any kind of good guy discount I can get on those?
我知道这听起来很傻。请问我能在这个上面享受任何类型的“好人折扣”吗？
No. We don't offer-- it's just whatever the vendor sells it for.
不行。我们不提供——价格就是供应商定的。
So there's no promotions that I'm missing out on?
所以没有什么我错过的促销活动吗？
No.
没有。
0 for two. She sends me on my way.
两次失败。她把我打发走了。
There you go. Have a good one.
给您。祝你过得愉快。
Have a good one. It's like have a nice day with all the friendly burned off. So Ira and I head outside.
你也是。这听起来就像是去掉了所有友好成分的“祝你愉快”。所以Ira和我走到外面。
You didn't push it very far. You still just kept it to one sentence before you caved.
你没怎么推销。你还没开始就妥协了，只说了一句话。
No, but I came back with, so there's not any sales or promotions that I'm missing out on? And she was like--
不，但我追问了：“所以没有什么我错过的促销活动吗？”然后她就——
But that's different than selling her the good guy discount.
但这和推销“好人折扣”是两码事。
You mean being like, come on, I'm a good guy.
你是说像这样：“拜托，我是个好人。”
Uh  huh. Yeah, you still haven't said that.
呃，是的。你还没说过那句话呢。
Oh, that feels-- but you know what? I feel like I could tell that she was going to say no.
噢，那感觉——但你知道吗？我觉得我看得出来她会说不。
No. No, I couldn't tell.
不，不。我看不出来。
And at that point, all you're getting is humiliated.
到了那个点，你只会感到羞辱。
We go around and around, until we remember, oh right, we can just find out. Ira goes back in.
我们反复讨论，直到我们想起：噢，对了，我们可以直接去问。Ira回到店里。
My friend was just in here and he tried to get a discount from you? He asked you for a good guy discount?
我朋友刚才来过这里，他想向你要个折扣？他问你要“好人折扣”？
Yeah.
是的。
Like five minutes ago?
就在五分钟前？
Yes. Yes, I recall.
是的，是的，我有印象。
Yeah. If he had pushed harder, could he have gotten a discount?
如果他更坚持一点，他能得到折扣吗？
No.
不能。
If he had been more charming, do you get an employee discount that you could have swiped a card and given him? Do you have any kind of discount at all? Do you have any kind of power to give him?
如果他更有魅力一点呢？你有没有员工折扣可以刷卡给他？你有没有任何折扣？你有任何权力给他折扣吗？
No. It's just the store policy.
没有。这是商店的政策。
So if your sister came in here or something, could you give he discount?
所以如果你的姐妹来这里，你能给她折扣吗？
No.
不能。
But you get a discount.
但你有折扣啊。
Right, which I'm rung up by another fellow manager or associate.
对，那是我由其他经理或同事结账时用的。
See? All of this brings us to attempt number three, record store. Yeah, they do still exist.
看到了吧？所有这些导致了第三次尝试，唱片店。是的，它们依然存在。
I grab what should amount to $70 worth of records. I go to the counter. Behind it, there's a serious record store guy-- black hoodie, black wool hat, hair sticking out of the front.
我拿了价值70美元的唱片。我走向柜台。后面站着一个严肃的唱片店伙计——黑色连帽衫，黑色羊毛帽，头发从前面冒出来。
How you doing?
你好吗？
Hey, is there any way I could get a good guy discount on those?
嘿，请问我能买这些唱片享受“好人折扣”吗？
No. No.
不能。不行。
Not like a bulk?
批发折扣也不行吗？
No. Not for new stuff.
不行。新货没有折扣。
No?
不给吗？
No. 'Cause we barely make a profit on that stuff. Yeah, so I'm afraid not.
不给。因为我们卖这些东西几乎没利润。所以，恐怕不行。
I mean, so many noes in such a tiny, tiny answer. I counted them. Five nos in 8.7 seconds. It's like a Russian nesting doll of no.
我是说，在这么简短的回答里，他说了这么多“不”。我数了数。8.7秒内说了五个“不”。简直像套娃一样的拒绝。
And really, I would argue it's hard to say no that thoroughly, unless you actually want to say no. Unless you think you're being asked for something stupid by someone stupid. This is what I believed would happen.
说真的，我想除非你真的想拒绝，否则很难把话说得这么绝。除非你觉得有人在问你蠢问题。这就是我预想会发生的事情。
And this one, it makes me 0 for three. And I gotta say, it felt bad. And it raises the obvious question, what does Sonari have that I don't?
而这一次，我三次全败。我不得不说，感觉很差。这引发了一个明显的问题：Sonari有什么是我没有的？
As we headed back to the office, Ira said, maybe he's just more charming and better looking. So I called Sonari, and I asked him something that I probably should have asked him before, which is exactly how often does this work for him?
当我们回到办公室时，Ira说，也许他只是更有魅力、长得更好看。所以我给Sonari打了电话，问了他一个我本来应该早点问的问题，那就是，这招对他来说到底有多频繁地成功？
I would say 15% to 20% of the time.
我想大概15%到20%的时间吧。
20%? That's actually a lot of noes.
20%？那其实会有很多次被拒绝。
He only gets one out of five. I tried three times. So I needed two more tries. Fine.
他每五次才能成功一次。我试了三次。所以我还需要两次尝试。好吧。
Hey.
嘿。
So here we are, number four. The item is a clock. And here we go.
我们到了，这是第四次。商品是一个时钟。我们要开始了。
Is there any way that you guys would give a good guy discount on that?
请问你们能在这个上面给个“好人折扣”吗？
No, I'm sorry.
不行，很抱歉。
No, not at all?
完全不行吗？
0 for four. I head to a small cookware shop. And if Sonari's stats are one in five, this is the big game. Do or die time. If the good guy discount is real for me, then this is it.
四次全败。我去了家小型厨具店。如果Sonari的成功率是五分之一，那这次就是决战时刻。成败在此一举。如果“好人折扣”对我来说是真的，那现在就是了。
Can I ask you, this All-Clad--
能问一下吗，这个All-Clad锅——
Mm hmm?
嗯？
Pot up here, would you guys ever give a good guy discount on this?
这个锅，你们会给“好人折扣”吗？
On All-Clad?
All-Clad的？
Yeah.
对。
You know, it's hard. I could probably do about 5%.
你知道，这很难。我或许可以给5%的折扣。
Like the sword from the stone, my friend. Behold, the good guy discount. Apparently, it can work for anybody. It'll work for you.
就像石中剑一样，我的朋友。瞧，这就是“好人折扣”。显然，它对谁都管用。它对你也管用。
But can we just stop for a second? Just stop. And I know that this is going to sound super earnest, and I'm real sorry about that. But I believe it, so I gotta say it.
但是我们能先停一下吗？真的。我知道这听起来非常真诚，我很抱歉。但我相信这一点，所以我必须说出来。
I don't think that you should try it. I'm not gonna try it again. Sorry, Sonari. I just don't think that we should go throwing around the term good guy like it's some kind of coupon. I think that good guy means something.
我不认为你应该尝试。我不会再试了。抱歉，Sonari。我只是觉得我们不应该到处乱用“好人”这个词，把它当成某种优惠券。我认为“好人”是有含义的。
Just the other day, I was with my son and my dad, and my kid is eating cake. He's two. He loves cakes. And he's got one bite left. And I say, can I have a bite?
就在几天前，我和儿子还有我父亲在一起，我孩子在吃蛋糕。他两岁，很爱吃。他只剩最后一口了。我说：“我能吃一口吗？”
And he looks up at me and he holds out his hand, offers me his last bite. And my dad says, what a good guy. When I was a kid, he used to say that to me too. I like the way the world looks during those moments. I think I'd rather have whatever that is than a discount.
他抬头看着我，伸出手，把最后一口递给了我。我父亲说：“真是个好人。”我小时候，他也会这样对我说。我喜欢在那些时刻看到的这个世界。我想我宁愿要那种感觉，而不是什么折扣。
Ben Calhoun.
Ben Calhoun。
Act Two, "The Heels on the Bus." So a test of whether or not you are a good guy, it can happen anywhere, as Mike Birbiglia well knows. He's a comedian and told this story onstage in New York.
第二幕，“公交车上的变态”。所以，测试你是否是好人，这随时随地都有可能发生，正如Mike Birbiglia所知。他是一位喜剧演员，曾在纽约的舞台上讲述了这个故事。
Last week I was meeting my wife in the city for dinner. And I went down to take the subway. And one of the unfortunate things about living in New York with the subway-- and you guys probably know this-- is sometimes on the weekends the subway is just off.
上周，我约了妻子在城里吃晚饭。我下楼去乘地铁。在纽约生活，乘坐地铁有个不幸的事情——你们可能知道——有时周末地铁会暂停服务。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And there'll just be a sign. There's just like, there isn't the subway. You know, and it'll say, you could take the bus. You know, it's written in pencil and there's an ellipsis, you know.
那里只会贴个告示。就像是说，没有地铁了。你知道，是用铅笔写的，后面还有个省略号。
And so last weekend that happened. And so I walked up to the bus and I said to the bus driver, hey, the subway's off. But it said that I could take the bus to the subway. Do you know where I can get off? And the bus driver said to me-- and I quote-- he goes, I don't know anything about the subway.
上周末就发生了这种情况。我走到公交车站，对公交司机说：“嘿，地铁停运了。但上面写着我可以乘公交车去地铁站。你知道我该在哪里下车吗？”公交司机对我说——引用他的原话——他说：“我不知道关于地铁的任何事。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I was like, you don't know anything about the subway? You're wearing the same outfit as the man running the subway.
我说：“你不知道地铁的事？你穿着和地铁司机一样的制服。”
If someone said to me, you see that guy walking down the street with the khaki shorts and the Kings of Leon t-shirt? You know anything about that guy? I'd be like, yeah, I'll tell you a few things about that guy. I know that he could use somebody.
如果有人对我说：“你看到那个穿着卡其短裤和Kings of Leon乐队T恤走在街上的人了吗？你知道关于那家伙的事吗？”我会说：“是啊，我能告诉你一些关于他的事。我知道他需要有人帮忙。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
There was only one other person on the bus. And it was this guy. And he looked up at me and he goes, I'm taking the subway. You can follow me.
公交车上只有另一个人。就是那个家伙。他抬头看我，说道：“我也去乘地铁。你可以跟着我。”
So now I'm in action film. I'm like, got it. I sit down, and I'm following this guy.
于是现在我像是置身于动作片里了。我想：好，明白了。我坐下，跟着这个家伙。
And then we go a few stops and this lady walks on to the bus. And she was a pretty lady. And she wasn't just bus pretty. She was pretty for the world.
车开了几站，一位女士上了公交车。她很漂亮。那种美不仅限于公交车的美，她是全世界公认的美。
And I did this thing that I sometimes do when I see a pretty lady, which is I looked at her long enough to realize that she was pretty, and then I looked at the floor. And then I never looked up again. That's my move.
我做了一件我看到漂亮女士时有时会做的事，那就是：我看着她直到意识到她很漂亮，然后我就盯着地板看。之后我再也没抬过头。这就是我的套路。
And so I'm looking at the floor. And then I'm looking up at this guy I'm about to follow, 'cause he's like my ride. But then he was staring at the lady.
所以我盯着地板。然后又看着我要跟随的那个家伙，因为他带我走。但接着，他一直盯着那位女士看。
And you know, I know we're all guilty of staring at some point or another. I think we've all done it. But I think that there's an etiquette to staring. I think that you can use your peripheral position if you want to look at somebody. You can stare at someone like you're inside of a spooky painting in Scooby-Doo where your face doesn't move, but then your eyes pan side to side like you're living in the walls of a mansion.
你知道，我知道我们都曾盯着某人看过。我想我们都做过。但我认为盯着人看是有礼仪的。如果你想看某人，你可以利用余光。你可以盯着某人看，就像《史酷比》里那种阴森的画一样，脸不动，但眼睛来回扫描，就像住在豪宅的墙里。
But this guy was not doing the spooky painting. He was just full on staring at this lady, like a gargoyle.
但那家伙做的不是阴森画。他就像个石像鬼一样盯着那女士。
And I was so mad. I was just like, we all want to stare at the lady. But we don't, because we are decent people. We have decided as a group that we are not going to stare at the pretty lady.
我太生气了。我心想：我们都想盯着那女士看。但我们没有，因为我们是体面人。我们作为一个群体已经决定了，我们不会盯着漂亮女士看。
But that's the difference between decent people and creepy people. Creepy people do the things that decent people want to do but have decided are probably not a great idea.
但这就是体面人和变态的区别。变态做了体面人想做但决定最好别做的事情。
Decent people are like, I would like to stare at that pretty lady, but it will make her feel uncomfortable. Creepy people are like, look. I'm going for it.
体面人会想：“我很想盯着那位美女看，但那会让她感到不安。”变态会想：“看吧，我就要看了。”
We go a few more stops and the creepy guy stands up, looks at me, and says, let's go. I was like, oh great. Now she thinks I'm with you.
又过了几站，那个变态站起来，看着我说：“走吧。”我想：噢，太好了。现在她以为我和你是一伙的了。
This pretty lady and I have built up a rapport where we have an understanding that she is pretty and I am decent. And when I am in her presence, I stare at the floor. And now she thinks I am with you, a creepy man?
这位美女和我建立了一种默契，她知道她很美，我也很体面。当我在她面前时，我盯着地板看。而现在她认为我和你，一个变态，是一伙的？
And so as I walk by this woman, I try to convey all of this with my eyes. Like, I am not with this guy. And that look takes so long to convey that the look itself becomes creepy. And I know it, and so I say, sorry, which were the first words uttered in a conversation we were not having.
所以当我从那个女人身边走过时，我试着用眼睛表达所有这些。像是在说：“我不认识这人。”这种眼神表达太久了，以至于眼神本身变得变态起来。我意识到了，所以我说了声“抱歉”，这成了我们还没开始的对话中的第一句词。
As this woman understands her bus ride, she walked onto a bus, a creepy man stared at her for 10 minutes and then left the bus. And then another man, who she did not know was on the bus, approached her and apologized, which means what he did is worse.
这位女士对公交行程的理解是：她上了一辆车，一个变态盯着她看了10分钟，然后离开了。接着另一个她本来不知道在车上的男人靠近她并道歉，这意味着他做的事情更糟糕。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
And I'm so frustrated about the unfairness of the situation that when I get to the dinner with my wife, I'm explaining this whole thing in detail. And I'm like, it's not fair because I am not creepy. I am decent.
我对这种情况的不公感到沮丧，所以当我赶到餐厅和妻子共进晚餐时，我详细地解释了这一切。我说：“这不公平，因为我不是变态。我是体面人。”
And my wife says, wait. Is the moral of the story that you want credit for just not being creepy? And I was like, exactly.
我妻子说：“等等。故事的寓意是你想因为‘没有变成变态’而获得奖励吗？”我说：“正是如此。”
Because I think that decent people are undervalued. I think that decent people should be treated like firemen. We should get a day and a calendar.
因为我认为体面人被低估了。我认为体面人应该像消防员一样被对待。我们应该有自己的节日。
One month there'd just be a guy carrying in porch furniture for the winter. One month there'd just be a guy grilling a veggie burger with an apron that says "Meatless in Seattle." My month, it'd just be me checking out at a pharmacy with tampons and a yogurt.
某个月会有一群人帮邻居把门廊家具搬进屋避冬。某个月会有一群人戴着写着“西雅图无肉”的围裙烤素汉堡。我的月份里，我也许就在药店结账，买了卫生棉和酸奶。
And my wife says, but you do get credit. I married you.
妻子说：“但你已经得到奖励了。我嫁给了你。”
Aww.
噢。
And I said, I want more than that.
我说：“我想得到的比这更多。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Mike Birbiglia. His comedy special, My Girlfriend's Boyfriend , is on Netflix.
Mike Birbiglia。他的喜剧特辑《我女朋友的男朋友》正在Netflix上播放。
Coming up, proving that you're a good guy to somebody who never, ever, ever will know what you did. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，向一个永远永远都不会知道你所作所为的人证明你是个好人。芝加哥公共广播电台，稍后节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, good guys. Stories of people trying to be good guys and not always sure if they're succeeding.
这里是《This American Life》。我是Ira Glass。今天我们的节目是“好人”。那些试图成为好人的人的故事，并不总能确定他们是否成功了。
We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, "No Man Left Behind." We now turn to a kind of classic story of a buddy who's trying to do a solid for another guy from Julia DeWitt.
我们进入了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“一个都不落下”。现在我们转向一个关于朋友试图为另一个兄弟两肋插刀的经典故事，来自Julia DeWitt。
Out in the desert scrub lands of northern South Africa, in a place called the Karoo, there's nothing, no trees, no water, for as far as you can see.
在南非北部的卡鲁荒野，那里空无一物，没有树木，没有水源，一眼望不到尽头。
You're in a primeval landscape.
你置身于原始地貌中。
This is Don Shirley. Why he knows this place so well will become clear in a minute.
这是Don Shirley。他为什么如此了解这个地方，稍后就会明了。
See a little rise. And when you get to the little hill, there's actually a big hollow where the ground's collapsed. At the bottom of a very steep slope, you actually have a sheer face in front of you. And at the bottom of this sheer face is a puddle.
看到一个小山包。当你走到小山丘时，其实有个巨大的凹陷，地面坍塌了。在陡峭斜坡的底部，你的面前是一堵笔直的岩壁。在那堵岩壁底部，有一个水坑。
And so you think, oh, this is just a little puddle that doesn't go anywhere. But when you take the duckweed off the top, it's actually clear water.
所以你以为，噢，这只是个死水坑，通向哪里。但当你把表面的浮萍拨开，其实是清澈的水。
Which means that this isn't just standing water. This water is filtering down to somewhere.
这意味着这不仅仅是积水。这些水正渗透到别处。
And if you go into this puddle, there's a small slot that goes through, which is just wide enough for a man's body to go through. After 20 foot, you're now starting to enter the cave. And gradually the cave gets wider.
如果你进入这个水坑，有一个很窄的裂缝，刚好够一个人穿过。走过20英尺后，你开始进入洞穴。慢慢地，洞穴变宽了。
Down below you is 900 feet of water. This is Bushman's Cave.
在你下方是900英尺深的水域。这就是布什曼洞穴（Bushman's Cave）。
It's a huge cave. Now, if you take the Eiffel Tower and stand it on the floor of the Bushman's Cave, the top of the tower would be just about coming out of the water.
这是一个巨大的洞穴。如果你把埃菲尔铁塔立在布什曼洞穴的底部，塔尖刚好能露出水面。
The cave is almost 1,000 feet deep and two and a half football fields wide. The main thing that lives in the pitch darkness is a species of strange little blind white cave shrimp. Otherwise, the cave is dark, deep, and dead.
洞穴深近1000英尺，宽达两个半橄榄球场。生活在漆黑环境中的主要生物是一种奇特的盲白色洞穴虾。除此之外，洞穴深暗、广袤且死寂。
This cave is a dangerous place for humans. And it's basically totally inaccessible to almost all of us. But for deep water divers, this is heaven.
这个洞穴对人类来说是个危险的地方。基本上，我们大多数人都无法进入。但对于深潜潜水员来说，这是天堂。
There are only a very few divers on the planet that have ever been anywhere near the bottom of this cave. And only about a dozen recreational divers ever dive to these kinds of depths, period.
世界上只有极少数潜水员曾接近过这个洞穴的底部。且总共只有十几名休闲潜水员曾潜入这种深度。
Don is one of these extreme divers. He met another of these deep water divers, a guy named Dave Shaw, back in 2002. They were immediately friends, and a couple of years later, Don took Dave to dive Bushman's.
Don是这些极限潜水员之一。他在2002年认识了另一位深潜潜水员，名叫Dave Shaw。他们立刻成了朋友，几年后，Don带Dave去潜布什曼洞穴。
On dive day, they got to the puddle and Dave went in first. Dave swam down through the slot, and the cave opened up below him.
潜水当天，他们到了水坑，Dave先下去。Dave游过裂缝，下方的洞穴豁然开朗。
While he was going down, he was doing something called laying a shot line. Basically, he was leaving a trail of rope in the total darkness. This is the only way he knew how to get out of the cave.
当他下潜时，他在执行一项任务，叫做布设引导绳。基本上，他是在漆黑一片中留下一条绳索路径。这是他知道离开洞穴的唯一方法。
You're in pitch black, absolute pitch black. So if you shine a light in any direction, it will disappear. The darkness will eat the light.
你身处绝对的漆黑中，伸手不见五指。所以如果你向任何方向打光，它都会消失。黑暗会吞噬光线。
Basically, being 900 foot in a cave, you might as well be on the moon. In fact, I think more people have walked on the moon than have actually been to those sort of depths in caves.
基本上，身处洞穴900英尺深处，你就像在月球上一样。事实上，我认为去过月球的人比曾到达这种深度的洞穴潜水员还要多。
This sounds unbelievable, but it's true. More people have been on the moon than have been to the depths that these guys have.
这听起来不可思议，但却是事实。去过月球的人比曾到达这些家伙探索深度的人还要多。
Now Dave was exploring on the bare floor of the cavern. There's nothing to see but his light in the black and the white rope that he dragged with him. Then suddenly--
当时Dave正在空旷的洞穴底部探索。除了他的灯光和身后拖着的白绳，什么也看不见。然后突然——
His torch caught the remains of Deon Dreyer.
他的手电筒照到了Deon Dreyer的遗骸。
No one knows exactly what happened to Deon Dreyer. But a decade earlier, Deon was diving with a team in Bushman's. When they stopped to take a headcount, Deon was gone. People had been looking for his body ever since.
没人确切知道Deon Dreyer发生了什么。但在十年前，Deon曾和团队在布什曼洞穴潜水。当他们停下来清点人数时，Deon不见了。从那以后，人们一直在寻找他的遗体。
He was still in his wetsuit, still wearing his cylinders-- a collection of bones inside a wetsuit. And at the time, he tried to move the body, but the body was stuck in the silt. He was panting and he said, I shouldn't work hard at this depth. It wasn't in the plan, so I needed to leave the body there.
他依然穿着潜水服，戴着气瓶——潜水服里是一堆骨头。当时，他试图移动遗体，但遗体卡在淤泥里。他气喘吁吁地说：“我不应该在这么深的地方费力工作。”这不是计划内的，所以我不得不把遗体留在那。
Deon was 20 when he was lost in Bushman's. Dave didn't take finding Deon lightly.
Deon失踪在布什曼洞穴时才20岁。Dave没有掉以轻心。
He thought of it more of a mission to actually-- his task to bring this body back.
他认为这更像是一项任务——他的职责是把这具遗体带回来。
So when Dave came up, he told Don he was going to come back and get Deon's body.
所以当Dave浮出水面时，他告诉Don他打算回来把Deon的遗体带走。
He phoned up Deon's parents and said, I'm going to retrieve your son's body.
他打电话给Deon的父母说：“我要去带回你们儿子的遗体。”
The thing is that a dive like this is a major operation. It took them months to plan.
问题是，这样的潜水是一项重大行动。他们花了几个月来计划。
You're at 900 foot under the water. There's a lot of risk involved in that. Every 33 foot that you go down effectively doubles the risk. When you're down at those depths, anything that goes wrong is an issue.
你在水下900英尺。这涉及巨大的风险。你每下潜33英尺，风险基本上就翻倍。当你在这种深度时，任何出错的地方都是问题。
Combining extreme depths with the hard work that Dave had to do to get Deon's body into a body bag came with a lot of risk. At depth, too much nitrogen is kind of like a narcotic. Basically it feels suddenly like you drank five martinis in a row.
将极端深度与Dave为了把遗体装入尸袋所需的辛苦工作结合起来，伴随着很大的风险。在深处，过量的氮就像一种麻醉剂。基本上你会突然觉得像一口气喝了五杯马提尼。
Too much helium can give you twitching fits. If you breathe too heavily, like Dave might have to while he's moving around Deon's body-- you pass out. And then of course, there's the bends.
过量的氦会导致痉挛。如果你呼吸过重，比如Dave在移动遗体时可能必须要做的那样——你会昏迷。然后当然，还有减压病。
If you come up too quickly, it's like opening a Coke bottle once you've shook it up and it fizzes. And then you would have problems with bubbles in your blood.
如果你浮起得太快，就像摇晃可乐瓶后打开瓶盖一样，会滋滋冒气。然后你的血液里会有气泡引发问题。
To prevent the bends, Dave would take several hours to come up to the surface. So they recruited a team of support divers that would go into the water at intervals to check on Dave at various depths while he came up.
为了防止减压病，Dave需要几个小时才能浮出水面。所以他们招募了一组支持潜水员，在不同的深度分阶段下水，在Dave上升的过程中检查他的状态。
And the rule was no one will go deeper than the depth where we actually plan for them to be.
规则是：没人会比我们计划让他们到达的深度更深。
Don would go the deepest.
Don会去最深的地方。
But as far as Dave and I were concerned, basically what we said is if Dave has a problem, he would signal me. And in caving, when you flash a light, you wave a light around, that's a distress signal.
但就Dave和我而言，我们基本上约定，如果Dave有问题，他会向我发出信号。在洞潜中，当你闪光、挥动灯光时，那就是求救信号。
We got to the day that we were actually planning to do the main dive. And we went down early in the morning. It was still dark. The sun was not quite up yet.
我们到了计划执行主潜的日子。我们清晨就出发了。当时还是黑的。太阳还没完全升起。
And at 6:15, Dave went under the water. I followed 14 minutes later.
6点15分，Dave下潜入水。我14分钟后跟着下潜。
Don followed the shot line down through the slot and into the cave.
Don沿着引导绳穿过裂缝进入洞穴。
So whilst I was going down, falling through this black space, I was expecting to see some rising bubbles as I was going down. Also, I would see Dave's light where he was coming back.
当我下潜，穿过这个黑暗空间时，我本以为能看到一些上升的气泡。我还应该能看到Dave回来时的灯光。
When I was going down, I didn't actually see any bubbles coming back. What I did see in the area where I thought he would actually be, I did see a light. It was one light, a solid light just shining.
当我下潜时，我实际上没看到任何气泡上来。在我以为他应该在的区域，我确实看到了一道光。是一道光，一道坚定的亮光。
But the light wasn't moving.
但光没有动。
Something's not quite right. And he's spending longer doing something. And then I knew that I would probably be going down to the bottom.
有些不对劲。他花的时间比预想的长。然后我知道我可能得下潜到底部了。
Don dove past 800 feet, deeper than he had ever been before.
Don潜过了800英尺，比他以往任何时候都要深。
Now I went past my target depth. But the problem was, as I got to 833 foot, I actually had my own personal problems go on then.
现在我超过了我的目标深度。但问题是，当我到了833英尺时，我遇到了我自己的个人问题。
He heard a sharp crack.
他听到了一声清脆的裂响。
[CRACK]
[裂响]
My re-breather controller actually imploded.
我的呼吸循环机控制器内爆了。
This just means a piece of his breathing apparatus broke. Don trained constantly for moments like this. So he knew exactly what to do. He would just add oxygen to his gas mixture manually.
这意味着他的呼吸装置的一个部件坏了。Don为这种时刻进行了不间断的训练。所以他确切地知道该做什么。他手动增加氧气混合物。
But at that sort of depth, any oxygen that you add makes a hell of a difference. And I pushed my oxygen pressure much too high inadvertently. Now that's very unhealthy at that depth-- very unhealthy. And I was liable to actually pass out very quickly.
但在那种深度，你添加的任何氧气都会造成巨大的影响。我不小心把氧气压力推得太高了。在那种深度，这非常不健康——非常不健康。我很快就会昏迷。
Don knew then that this was it. It was the end of the line. He had to turn around and go back.
Don当时就知道，到头了。这就是尽头。他必须掉头回去。
The surface is not somewhere that you can actually go to solve a problem. When you have a problem, you have to solve that problem there where you are. And if you don't solve that problem, you don't come back. You have to put the brakes on, as it were, at that point.
水面不是你遇到问题时可以逃去解决的地方。当你遇到问题，你必须在你所在的地方解决它。如果你解决不了，你就回不来。你必须在那个点上踩刹车，可以说。
And I was thinking, OK, Dave might come back. He's either dead or he's working his way back. But all I could deal with was what was in front of me.
我在想，OK，Dave可能会回来。他要么死了，要么正在努力回来。但我只能处理眼下的事情。
Don knew that he now had over 10 hours in the water ahead of him. Don slowly ascended up to the roof of the cave. At this point, he started to pass out. And then he got a helium bubble in his ear.
Don知道他还有10个小时在水下的路程要走。Don慢慢上升到洞顶。此时，他开始昏迷。然后他的耳朵里进了一个氦气泡。
And that made me lose balance completely. I'm over this extreme depth of water. You then have absolutely no sense of up, down, sideways, or anything. And I didn't really have any sense of really where I was.
这让我完全失去了平衡。我在这个深不见底的水域之上。你完全没有了上下左右的概念。我真的不知道我在哪里。
Don lost grip on the shot line. And as he was passing out, reviving again, and passing out, he started swimming in these little circles, spinning around, looking for the line. Remember, this line is the only way Don knows how to get out of the cave.
Don松开了引导绳。当他昏迷、恢复意识、又昏迷时，他开始游泳，打着小圈，转来转去，寻找绳子。记住，这条绳子是Don离开洞穴的唯一方法。
And I'm in this void, the black. I have an extremely bright light in my hand. And where the light was going into the black, I was seeing black. And where the light was hitting the roof, I was seeing light, white. And then I'd keep spinning around like that.
我在这片虚空中，漆黑。我的手里拿着极亮的光。当光射进黑暗时，我看到的是黑暗。当光照在洞顶时，我看到的是光，白色。然后我就一直那样转着。
So I was seeing black, white, black, white, black, white. And then I caught the line, the white line, in my torch. And the next time I spun round, I grabbed hold of the line.
我看到黑、白、黑、白、黑、白。然后我的手电筒捕捉到了那条绳子，白色的绳子。下一次转圈时，我抓住了绳子。
The trouble was now I had vertigo and that makes you vomit. So now I was vomiting under water as well. Vomiting in between breaths, effectively. As time went on, I couldn't breathe anymore.
麻烦的是，我得了眩晕症，这会让你呕吐。所以现在我在水下也呕吐了。实际上是在呼吸的间隙呕吐。随着时间推移，我无法呼吸了。
Don eventually stabilized himself and he started his ascent again towards the surface. He met a support diver, and using a waterproof pencil and one of these slates the divers use to communicate underwater, Don wrote him a message.
Don最终稳住了自己，再次开始向水面上升。他遇到了一名支持潜水员，利用防水笔和潜水员在水下交流用的写字板，Don写下了一条信息。
I said, I'm OK and Dave's not coming back. But still in my mind, I had a hope that he would. From that point on, the guys had a task, which was to support me.
我说：“我没事，但Dave回不来了。”但在我的脑海里，我依然希望他能回来。从那点开始，伙计们的任务就是支持我。
For hours, the team up above waited to see if he would make it out alive. His only job was to breathe. Dave's light down below had disappeared.
几个小时里，上方的团队在等待他是否能活着出来。他唯一的任务就是呼吸。下方Dave的灯光已经消失了。
If you see the videos of me coming up, you'd think this guy's half dead. You know, it had been just over 12 hours in the water. I couldn't actually really do much for myself other than breathe. My head was like a marshmallow.
如果你看我浮出水面的视频，你会觉得这人半死不活。你知道，在水下待了刚超过12个小时。除了呼吸，我实际上做不了多少事。我的头就像棉花糖一样。
Don was put into a decompression chamber and then taken in the morning for more treatment at a hospital in Johannesburg. Dave did not come up that night. Dave was dead. And then a week later, Don got some news.
Don被放进了减压舱，第二天被带到约翰内斯堡的一家医院进行更多治疗。Dave那天晚上没有浮上来。Dave死了。一周后，Don得到了一些消息。
I actually was told that Dave's body had come up. During that week, there'd been lots of speculation as to what had happened.
我其实被告知Dave的遗体浮上来了。在那周里，对于发生了什么有很多推测。
Dave was carrying a camera on his head. In retrieving the camera, then we could piece together really what happened.
Dave头上带着摄像头。找回摄像头后，我们就能还原到底发生了什么。
As the camera rolls, you see Dave trying to get Deon's body into a body bag.
随着画面滚动，你看到Dave试图把Deon的遗体放进尸袋。
One of his lights had actually got tangled up in the line and smashed. So now, bearing in mind you're in the pitch black, his main light had actually been broken. So he couldn't really see so well.
他的一盏灯缠在了绳子上并撞碎了。请记住你身处漆黑一片中，他的主灯坏了。所以他看不清。
Then Dave also gets tangled. He pulls away, but now he's tied to Deon's body.
然后Dave也被缠住了。他挣脱了，但现在他被绑在Deon的遗体上。
And you could see that he was working trying to get himself out of this line. He was cutting with the scissors. But his scissors weren't even getting anywhere near the line.
你可以看到他正在努力把自己从绳子里弄出来。他在用剪刀剪。但剪刀甚至根本没剪到绳子上。
Listening to the video, you can hear Dave's breathing start to get shallower and shallower as he starts working harder and harder.
听着视频，你可以听到Dave的呼吸随着他越来越用力，开始变得越来越浅。
Dave passed out from too much carbon dioxide. You know, he worked right up, right up to the very last breath that he ever took trying to get out. And then the camera just carries on recording until the batteries run out.
Dave因为过多的二氧化碳昏迷了。你知道，他一直工作到他吸入的最后一口气，试图脱困。然后摄像头继续录制，直到电池耗尽。
There's barely a day goes by where I don't think of Dave. And really, there are a lot of times I turn round-- I do a fantastic dive and I just want to say, did you see that?
几乎没有一天我不想到Dave。而且有很多时候我会转身——我完成了一次精彩的潜水，我只想说：“你看到那个了吗？”
And Dave very much did die nobly doing what he did. He did everything that he should do. And he died, as they'd say in the military, with his boots on.
Dave确实高尚地死在了他的岗位上。他做了他该做的一切。他就像军队里所说的那样，死在了阵地上。
When Dave's body had come up, hanging underneath Dave's body, cocooned in the line that Dave originally had laid, was Deon Dreyer's body. So Dave actually achieved what he wanted to do.
当Dave的遗体浮上来时，悬在Dave遗体下方的，茧在Dave最初铺设的绳子里的，正是Deon Dreyer的遗体。所以Dave确实达成了他想做的事。
This story came from Julia DeWitt. It was first broadcast on the public radio show Snap Judgment . If you want to hear more stories like that one, Snap Judgment is on many public radio stations. And it's also a podcast, which you can find at snapjudgment.org or the iTunes store or wherever it is that you get your podcasts.
这个故事来自Julia DeWitt。它最初是在公共广播节目《Snap Judgment》上播出的。如果你想听更多那样的故事，《Snap Judgment》在许多公共广播电台都有播出。它也是个播客，你可以在snapjudgment.org或者iTunes商店，或者任何你获取播客的地方找到它。
Act Four, "The Test." So all this hour, we've been hearing about guys trying to be good guys and being tested and trying to do the right thing.
第四幕，“测试”。在这一小时里，我们一直在听关于人们试图成为好人、被考验并试图做正确之事的各种故事。
But of course, sometimes that is really hard. Sometimes you're not up to it. You look around at your life and you realize things are not exactly right, and it's not clear how to fix them and how to be a good guy. And so you just take a step forward on whatever path appears right then in front of you, whatever that path is.
当然，有时这真的很难。有时你应付不来。你环顾自己的生活，意识到事情并不完全正确，也不清楚该如何解决，该如何做一个好人。所以你只是顺着眼前出现的任何路径向前迈了一步，无论那条路是什么。
I was hired to interview men and women in the state of Utah who receive Medicaid support for treatment of mental illnesses generally diagnosed as schizophrenia.
我受聘去采访犹他州接受医疗补助以治疗通常被诊断为精神分裂症的心理疾病的男女。
That's Scott Carrier, who took that job after working on and off as a radio reporter out of Salt Lake City. He was hired for the interviewing job because the director of this research project heard some of Scott's radio stories and thought he was a good interviewer, somebody who knew how to listen.
那是Scott Carrier，他在盐湖城断断续续做广播记者后接受了那份工作。他受聘做这项采访工作，是因为这个研究项目的负责人听过他的一些广播报道，认为他是个很好的采访者，懂得如何倾听。
The researchers taught Scott how to administer this test, which measured mental health. It was 100 questions, each of which was scored on a scale of one to seven.
研究人员教Scott如何执行这项测量心理健康的测试。共有100个问题，每个问题都按1到7的等级评分。
Took an hour to give the test. Scott was paid $30 for each test he gave. The people he gave the test to got $5.
测试需要一小时。Scott每做一个测试获得30美元酬劳。他采访的人每人获得5美元。
I had little understanding of schizophrenia before I began, and I have little more understanding now. I took the job because I had no other. I took the job because I'd just quit my steady job, my professional job, after realizing that what I wanted more than anything was to put my boss on the floor and stand on his throat and watch him gag.
开始之前，我对精神分裂症所知甚少，现在依然如此。我接这份工作是因为没有别的。我接这份工作是因为我刚辞去了稳定的工作，专业的工作，在意识到我最想做的事是把老板按在地板上，踩在他的喉咙上看着他窒息之后。
Then my wife moved out, took the kids and everything. She said, I've thought about it, and I really think it's the best thing for me at this time in my life.
然后妻子搬走了，带走了孩子和一切。她说：“我想过了，我真的认为这对我现阶段的生活来说是最好的选择。”
And so I took the job interviewing schizophrenics because it was offered to me and because it was all there seemed to be. And it seemed somehow predestined, a karmic response that could not be avoided.
所以我接受了这份采访精神分裂症患者的工作，因为它摆在面前，而且看起来只有这一份可做。这似乎是命中注定的，是一种无法回避的业力回应。
It would only be temporary, something to get through the summer. And I was told that they needed someone willing to drive around the state through the small towns, searching out individuals who are often transient and prone to hiding. I like to drive. I like to travel. And I like the idea of pursuit. So I took the job, and did the job, and my life will never be the same.
这只是暂时的，只是为了熬过夏天。有人告诉我，他们需要一个愿意开车环绕该州穿过小城镇的人，寻找那些通常行踪不定且倾向于躲藏的个人。我喜欢开车。我喜欢旅行。我喜欢追求的想法。所以我接了这份工作，做了这份工作，我的生活再也回不去了。
The patient is 21 years old and has lived with his parents since his discharge from the Army. He has no friends, no recreational activities, and no social life. He spends his time writing and reading, but these activities do not give him any pleasure.
这位患者21岁，自从从军队退伍后就一直和父母住在一起。他没有朋友，没有娱乐活动，没有社交生活。他把时间花在写作和阅读上，但这些活动并没有给他带来任何快乐。
He has lost weight, has general anxiety and loss of libido, and occasional feelings of unreality. He is worried about his unpredictable behavior, for example, getting down on all fours and chewing the grass because he was thinking what it would be like to be a cow.
他体重下降，有普遍的焦虑感和性欲减退，偶尔会有不真实感。他担心自己不可预测的行为，例如因为思考像牛一样是什么感觉而四肢着地吃草。
The patient is 25 years old and believes that she is the devil and therefore responsible for all the evil in the world. She's not been out of her house for seven days, and only comes down from her room for meals.
这位患者25岁，相信自己是魔鬼，因此要为世界上所有的邪恶负责。她已经七天没出过家门了，只有用餐时才会下楼。
A few days ago, her mother walked into her room and found her crying. She asked her mother what was the most painful punishment that one human being could inflict upon another. The mother tried to get the reason for this question and her daughter mumbled something about the devil having to be punished for the benefit of humanity, something about having to die for his sins.
几天前，她母亲走进房间发现她在哭。她问母亲人类能给予另一个人最痛苦的惩罚是什么。母亲试着问她原因，她女儿嘟囔着什么关于“魔鬼必须为了人类的利益受到惩罚”，以及什么“为了他的罪孽必须去死”。
When the mother asked her if she still thought she was the devil, she answered, let's not get into that again. It only upsets you and you don't believe me anyway, even when the evidence is all around you, plain for you to see.
当母亲问她是否仍然认为自己是魔鬼时，她回答：“我们别再谈这个了。这只会让你难过，而且你反正也不相信我，即使证据就在周围，显而易见。”
The people I interview are all so sad, so lonely with such thin souls, like ghosts and demons have invaded their hearts and are sucking their souls dry. A person's soul should be like an ocean. But a schizophrenic's soul is like a pool of rain in a parking lot. They suffer and they are completely alone in their suffering, and there's nothing I can do, nothing anyone can do to bring them back.
我采访的人都如此悲伤、如此孤独，灵魂如此薄弱，就像幽灵和魔鬼入侵了他们的心，正在把他们的灵魂吸干。一个人的灵魂应该像大海。但精神分裂症患者的灵魂就像停车场里的雨水坑。他们受苦，在痛苦中完全孤独，我无能为力，没人能把他们拉回来。
I come home at night and cry. I sob like a three-year-old.
我晚上回到家就会哭。像个三岁小孩一样啜泣。
Today, halfway through an interview with a man in Tooele, he says, I have a crystal in my pouch. Do you want to see it?
今天，在Tooele采访一个男人到一半时，他说：“我的小袋子里有个水晶。你想看看吗？”
I say OK and he takes it out, a normal crystal the size of a large paper clip. And he says, I can look through this, and it will tell me whether you're a good person or a bad person. What do you want me to do? Do you want me to look through it or not?
我说OK，他把它拿了出来，是一个正常的大号回形针大小的水晶。他说：“我可以透过它看，它会告诉我你是好人还是坏人。你想让我怎么做？你想让我透过它看还是不看？”
My first thought is to say, do you want to go on with the interview? Maybe when we're done, you can look through the crystal. But then I realize that he's really asking me to take his test, just like I'm asking him to take mine.
我首先想到的是说：“你想继续采访吗？也许等我们做完了，你可以透过水晶看看。”但随后我意识到他是在让我参加他的测试，就像我在让他参加我的测试一样。
I come into his house. I ask him very personal questions, and I expect him to answer honestly. And why should he?
我走进他的屋子。我问他非常私人的问题，我期望他诚实回答。可为什么他要诚实呢？
So I say, OK, go ahead. And he puts the crystal up to his eye, turns it clockwise and counterclockwise, back and forth, squinting, looking me up and down.
所以我说：“OK，请吧。”他把水晶放到眼前，顺时针和逆时针转动，来回反复，眯起眼睛，上下打量着我。
And he says, I can't tell for sure. I'm going to have to read your mind. Here, take my hand.
他说：“我不能确定。我得读读你的思想。来，握住我的手。”
He holds out his right hand with the crystal resting in the palm. I take his hand, and he puts his left hand over mine and squeezes it tight and shakes it and goes into a small spasm.
他伸出右手，水晶躺在掌心。我握住他的手，他用左手盖住我的手，紧紧捏住，摇晃着，然后陷入了轻微的痉挛。
Then he lets go and sort of sits back like he's exhausted. He asks me if I felt anything. And I say, maybe a little.
然后他放开了，像精疲力竭一样坐了回去。他问我有没有感觉到什么。我说：“也许有一点。”
And he says, I sent you a message. I put it in your mind. I told you what is wrong with me.
他说：“我发信息给你了。我把它传进了你的思想。我告诉你我有什么问题了。”
I'm not supposed to figure out what's wrong with these people. I'm just supposed to ask the questions and score the answers from one to seven. This is partly because I'm not a doctor, and might get something going that I wouldn't know how to contain. But it's mainly because my supervisors want clean data. They want all the people asking the questions to be doing it in the same way.
我不应该去搞清楚这些人有什么问题。我只是应该问问题，给答案打1到7分。这部分是因为我不是医生，可能会引发我无法控制的事情。但主要是因为我的主管们需要干净的数据。他们想要所有问问题的人都以同样的方式去做。
I'm not supposed to get emotional. I'm not supposed to let the patient get emotional.
我不应该情绪化。我不应该让患者情绪化。
The therapy part of the county mental health system is in another department. I wouldn't even know what number to call. And I've been told more than once not to worry about it. I should never have let him take the crystal out of his pouch.
县心理健康系统的治疗部分在另一个部门。我甚至不知道该打什么号码。我被不止一次告知不要担心。我根本不该让他把水晶从袋子里拿出来。
I drove around all day trying to find a Navajo man. He lives very close to the Four Corners, the cross where Utah, Colorado, New Mexico, and Arizona meet.
我开车绕了一整天试图找一个纳瓦霍人。他住在离四角地（Four Corners）很近的地方，即犹他州、科罗拉多州、新墨西哥州和亚利桑那州的交界处。
It's all dirt roads, a house every five miles or so. No addresses, no phones. I stop at every house and knock on the door. But either nobody's home or nobody will answer.
全是土路，大概每五英里有一座房子。没有地址，没有电话。我在每栋房子前停下敲门。但要么没人，要么没人回答。
I flag down every car that passes and ask directions, and the people offer complicated directions that I follow as best as possible, sometimes driving for 20 or 30 miles. But it's always the wrong place or nobody's home or there just isn't a house there at all.
我拦住每辆路过的车问路，人们给出的复杂的路线，我尽可能遵循，有时开了20或30英里。但总是在错的地方，或者没人，或者那里根本没有房子。
Driving around, I think about how I have some of the same problems as the people I interview. I'm angry, depressed, prone to paranoid delusions, and I worry a lot.
开车兜圈时，我想着我怎么有和我采访的人一样的问题。我很愤怒，沮丧，容易出现偏执妄想，而且我很担心。
Up to now, I thought these were common problems and that I was more or less able to control them. But now I don't know. I feel like I'm just faking it.
直到现在，我还以为这些都是常见问题，我或多或少能控制住它们。但现在我不知道了。我觉得我只是在伪装。
Eventually, late in the afternoon, I find the man, or at least I think he's the man. I'm a third of the way through the test before I realize he's not the right guy.
最终，傍晚时分，我找到了那个人，或者至少我觉得是那个人。测试做到三分之一时，我才意识到他不是我要找的人。
When was your last visit to a mental health clinic? I don't go to a clinic. When did you last see a doctor? I don't have a doctor.
你上次去心理健康诊所是什么时候？我没去诊所。你上次看医生是什么时候？我没医生。
Do you blame yourself for anything you've done or not done? No. Have you felt more self-confident than usual? No.
你对自己做过或没做过的事感到内疚吗？没有。你感觉比平时更自信吗？没有。
Have you heard voices or other things that weren't there or that other people couldn't hear or seen things that weren't there? And he says, I think you want to talk to my son. And I ask him what his son's name is, and he says, same as mine.
你是否听到过不存在的声音或其他事物，或者是别人听不到的声音，或者是看到过不存在的东西？他说：“我觉得你想找我儿子谈谈。”我问他儿子叫什么，他说：“和我同名。”
I come back the next morning and interview the son in the kitchen. They make coffee for me on a propane camp stove as the house has no electricity.
第二天早上我回来，在厨房里采访他儿子。他们在丙烷野营炉上为我煮咖啡，因为屋里没电。
The son is 19 years old, a good looking kid, tall, healthy. Says used to run cross country in high school. He seems to be fine.
儿子19岁，长得很帅，个子高，健康。说高中时曾跑越野。他看起来没事。
But as I go through the questions, he starts to fix his eyes on mine, a direct, almost hypnotic stare straight into my head, like he's trying to pull me in and trap me. I try to look back, to look just as deeply into his mind. But it's like looking into a cave.
但随着问题的进行，他开始盯着我的眼睛看，一种直接的、近乎催眠的直视，仿佛想把我吸进去困住。我试着回看，试图同样深地看进他的思想里。但这就像看着一个洞穴。
He says he hears voices, satanic voices, and that he worries a lot about his shoes, that they're not the right kind, not the kind he sees on MTV. I can't tell if he's sick or if he's just trying to torture me.
他说他听到了声音，撒旦的声音，他很担心自己的鞋，说它们不对，不是他在MTV上看到的那种。我无法判断他是有病，还是只是想折磨我。
And I drive away thinking I don't know anything about this disease, that I know even less than when I started. I spent two days driving around, and I made $30. And I feel really, really tired.
我开车离开时想，我对这种疾病一无所知，我知道的比开始时还要少。我花了两天时间开车绕路，只赚了30美元。我感到非常、非常累。
The house is dark, as all the windows have heavy curtains pulled nearly shut. The curtains over the big picture window in the living room are open just a bit, and the light cuts through like a laser beam and hits the red shag carpet, throwing up small dust particles and cigarette ash.
屋里很暗，所有窗户都拉着厚重的窗帘。客厅大落地窗的窗帘开了一点，光像激光束一样切入，照在红色的毛毯上，激起微小的尘粒和香烟灰。
Two feet away from the light, near the television, is a slice of pizza lying upside down in the carpet. I'm interviewing the woman-- a mother-- and her teenage daughter's on the phone talking to her boyfriend, or rather a series of boyfriends who call and call. And all of them want her to go out right now, but her mother won't let her.
离光线两英尺远，电视机旁，有一片披萨倒扣在毯子上。我正在采访那个女人——一个母亲——她的少女女儿正在打电话和男朋友聊天，或者说是一系列打电话的男朋友。他们都想让她现在出去，但她母亲不让。
She's trying to answer my questions, trying to concentrate and be polite. But she's mainly listening to what her daughter is saying on the phone and will suddenly switch from saying, no, no, I've been feeling fine, I haven't had a relapse in months, to screaming out, is that John? I told you never to talk to him again.
她正试图回答我的问题，试图集中精神表现得礼貌。但她主要在听女儿电话里说的话，突然从说“不，不，我感觉一直很好，我已经几个月没复发了”转向尖叫道：“那是John吗？我告诉过你永远别再跟他说话了。”
Or, who is it? Is it a boy? You can't go out. Tell him he has to come over here.
或者是：“是谁？是个男孩吗？你不能出去。告诉他，他必须来这儿。”
I can't stop looking at the slice of pizza on the carpet. I keep looking at the slice of pizza because it's the only clue that the woman is sick. I mean, she has a teenage daughter and a dirty house. And maybe she shouldn't try to wear makeup to bed. But these are not necessarily symptoms of schizophrenia.
我忍不住盯着毯子上的那片披萨。我一直盯着那片披萨，因为那是那个女人有病的唯一线索。我是说，她有个少女女儿，房子很脏。也许她不该试着带妆睡觉。但这些未必是精神分裂症的症状。
She seems to be fine, just worn out, until I get to the question have you been worrying a lot? And she says yes, she has. She's been worrying a lot that the elders of the church-- the Mormon church-- will take her daughter away from her.
她看起来还好，只是累坏了，直到我问到“你最近担心很多吗？”她说是的。她一直很担心教会的长老——摩门教——会把她女儿从她身边带走。
And I ask her why, and she says, because she stopped taking her medication. And I ask her why did you stop taking your medication? And she says that the only reason she takes it is because she told her bishop that she was visited by the Archangel Gabriel and that she'd had sex with him. And then she was also visited by the Archangel Michael and that she'd had sex with both of them at once and that they'd ravished her almost every night.
我问她为什么，她说，因为她停止服用药物了。我问她为什么停药？她说她吃药的唯一理由是她告诉过主教，大天使加百列曾造访她，并且她和他发生了性关系。然后大天使米迦勒也造访了她，她同时和他们两个发生了性关系，他们几乎每晚都蹂躏她。
So her bishop made her go to a doctor. And the doctor gave her some pills, and she took the pills, and the angels stopped coming. The bishop and the elders had told her that if she had sex with any more angels, they'd take her daughter away.
所以主教强迫她去看医生。医生给了她一些药丸，她吃了药，天使们就不再来了。主教和长老们告诉她，如果她再和任何天使发生性关系，他们就会把她女儿带走。
So I ask her again why she stopped taking her medication, and she says, I'm lonely. I miss them. I want them to come back.
所以我再问她为什么停药，她说：“我很孤独。我想念他们。我想要他们回来。”
Today in a restaurant, eating lunch between interviews, I decided to take the test. I answered the questions and scored myself appropriately. And at some point, I realized I wasn't doing so well.
今天在餐馆，在采访间隙吃午餐时，我决定做这个测试。我回答了问题，适当地给给自己评分。某一刻，我意识到我做得不怎么样。
I decided not to even add up the points, because then I'd be left with a score and I'd never forget it. If I were to write a report on myself, it would sound something like this.
我决定甚至不去加总分数，因为那样我就有了一个分数，我永远也忘不掉。如果我要写一份关于我自己的报告，它听起来会是这样的。
The patient is 36 years old and lives alone since his wife left him three weeks ago. She took the kids and all the silverware, except for a large knife and a bowl and a coffee cup.
患者36岁，自从三周前妻子离开后独自居住。她带走了孩子和所有的餐具，除了一把大刀、一个碗和一个咖啡杯。
The patient admits that her leaving may have had something to do with the fact that, without warning, he completely gutted the house, tore out all the walls and ceilings, all the lathe and plaster right down to the studs. He says he did this in order to live like a primitive. When asked if he was successful, he says it was the first step in the right direction.
患者承认她离开可能与这一事实有关：毫无预兆地，他把房子彻底掏空了，拆掉了所有的墙壁和天花板，所有的板条和石膏板一直拆到龙骨。他说他这样做是为了像原始人一样生活。当被问及是否成功时，他说这是朝正确方向迈出的第一步。
The patient is a 36-year-old male who lives alone since his wife and children left him two months ago. He says there's a darkness that separates him from other people, a heavy darkness, like looking at a person from the bottom of a well.
患者是一名36岁男性，自从两个月前妻子和孩子离开他后独自居住。他说有一道黑暗将他与其他人隔开，一道沉重的黑暗，就像从井底看着一个人。
He believes that if he could say the right words, then the darkness would go away. He says he sometimes knows the right words, but cannot say them. Other times, he can't even think of the words to say.
他相信如果他能说出正确的词，黑暗就会消失。他说他有时知道正确的词，但说不出来。其他时候，他甚至连要说的词都想不出来。
The patient is 36 years old and lives alone since his wife and children left him three months ago. Last week, he went fishing in the San Juans and now believes that there's no better fisherman than himself.
患者36岁，自从三个月前妻子和孩子离开后独自居住。上周，他在圣胡安钓鱼，现在相信没有比他更出色的钓鱼者了。
He says, I can't tell you about it, because talking about fishing is silly, like farting and tap dancing at the same time. All I can say is I walk around in the water and I know the instant the fish will jump for the fly. I cut open their stomachs and squeeze out the bugs in my hand, study what they eat, how it all gets digested, even the exoskeleton and wings.
他说：“我不能告诉你，因为谈论钓鱼很傻，就像同时放屁和踢踏舞一样。我只能说我在水里走来走去，我知道鱼儿跳起来咬钩的那一瞬间。我切开它们的肚子，把虫子挤在手里，研究它们吃什么，这一切是如何消化的，甚至是外骨骼和翅膀。”
He says he was sick before, but now he's OK, and that it was the fly rod, just holding the rod in his hand, that cured him. His house is clean. The electricity is on. The walls have been sheet rocked and painted white. He says, I'll have to ask her, beg her, and maybe she'll come back.
他说他以前有病，但现在好了，是飞钓竿，仅仅是手里拿着竿子，治愈了他。他的屋子很干净。电通了。墙壁已经钉好板材并漆成了白色。他说：“我得求她，恳求她，也许她会回来。”
Scott Carrier. We first broadcast this story years ago.
Scott Carrier。我们几年前首次播出了这个故事。
Scott recently has just started a new podcast. It's called Home of the Brave. If you've heard him on our radio show over the years, you know he is really like nobody else on the radio. He's just a complete original, an amazing writer, great interviewer in stories where he does interviews. I, and many of us in public radio are like, super fans, and so it's exciting to see him finally have his own show.
Scott最近刚开始一个新的播客。叫《勇敢者的家》（Home of the Brave）。如果你多年来在我们的广播节目中听过他，你就知道他真的是电台里独一无二的人。他是一个彻底的原创，一个了不起的作家，在采访中非常棒。我，以及我们公共广播电台的许多人都非常喜欢他，所以看到他终于拥有了自己的节目真是太令人兴奋了。
Again the name, Home of the Brave. It's free. You can find it at homebrave.com or at the iTunes store or Stitcher, or like we say here on the show, wherever you get your podcasts.
再说一次名字，《Home of the Brave》。它是免费的。你可以在homebrave.com或者iTunes商店或者Stitcher上找到它，或者就像我们在节目里说的，在任何你获取播客的地方。
Our program was produced today by Brian Reed and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Simon Adler.
今天的节目由Brian Reed和我制作，Alex Blumberg、Ben Calhoun、Sarah Koenig、Miki Meek、Jonathan Menjivar、Robyn Semien、Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike参与。我们的资深制作人是Julie Snyder。制作帮助来自Simon Adler。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website.
Seth Lind是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon是我们的制作经理。Elise Bergerson是我们的办公室经理。Adrianne Mathiowetz负责我们的网站。
Music help today from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis. Mike Birbiglia was recorded at UCB East in Manhattan and Littlefield in Brooklyn.
今天的音乐帮助来自Damien Graef和Rob Geddis。Mike Birbiglia的录音地点在曼哈顿的UCB East和布鲁克林的Littlefield。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《This American Life》由PRX公共广播交易中心传送给公共广播电台。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, his new plastic surgery is, I don't know. It's just at that awkward phase.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。你知道，他的新整容手术，我不知道。它正处于那个尴尬阶段。
Where your face doesn't move, but then your eyes pan side to side.
你的脸不动，但接着你的眼睛来回扫描。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周回来，带来更多《This American Life》的故事。